- For real though, you
have a lot of tattoos.
What are your tattoos?
- This is a Hawaiian tattoo,
it's like an aumakua.
This is the shark.
The mono, is my, like, protector.
- Wow. That's cool.
- And then this is for my grandfather.
- You're wearing a scrunchie.
Only a hot man can pull off a scrunchie.
I'm just sayin'.
You gotta be blessed
to be rockin' a pink scrunchie.
Like, what's it like to be you,
just walk out everyday you
can wear anything you want?
- I like pink.
I like pink. I don't know what it is.
- No, I do too.
You look great, but I'm
just sayin', not everyone,
not every man out there,
if we said, "Hey, every
man out there right now,
just walk out in some
pink, put a scrunchie on",
it's gonna look different (laughs).
It's gonna look different.
You're blessed.
All these men are blessed, it' amazing.
No, I did see something though.
I know you have tattoos,
but I saw on SNL recently,
you had to wear something
else on your chest.
Did that hurt?
- Oh.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, I've never had my uh,
a nipple glued on to my nipple before, so.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Jason] Nor have I wore...
- [Kelly] (laughs).
Look, is that your mom?
- [Jason] That's my mom.
- [Kelly] You're putting on
nipples in front of your mom.
- [Jason] My mom, my mom's like in horror.
She's just staring like...
- [Audience] (laughing)
- I love your mom for
being down with that.
- [Audience] (cheering)
- Okay.
Oh my god.
- Each their own.
- So wait.
Do you always, because
every picture I see you in,
you always look like you workout all day.
Like, do you always...
Don't tell me that.
- I, I'm...
- Do you?
Is this natural?
Is this genetic?
- It's like a Hawaiian...
I'm not a fan of working out.
- I'm so depressed.
- Well we work out so much.
Like, Aquaman, it's all the
time, and so when we're done,
I haven't touched a
weight since we wrapped,
which is like two and a half years ago.
It's just too much.
- Such a blessing for you.
Do you eat really healthy?
- No.
I mean, I mean I eat slightly healthy.
I eat slightly healthy
= Arrgh!
Oh my God.
What??
- I'm not a sweets fan.
- Oh, okay, you've lost me.
Okay.
Yup.
- I love cheese.
- Oh I love cheese.
And wine.
A charcuterie board.
- Yeah, yeah, that whole thing.
- Yes.
- Packed full of salt.
Yeah, I'm a salt...
- No I love that you brought
your mom to SNL though.
Has she ever been star struck?
- Oh yeah, but I'm the
same way, though, I get...
- [Kelly] I do too, I nerd out.
- I do, I do I totally get gas.
- I think that it's sad
when you're not like that.
- [Jason] For sure.
- I think you've lost
that child-like, like,
"Oh my God it's exciting!" kind of thing.
- Yeah.
My favorite thing was,
I saw a picture of you,
was it Barbara Streisand?
- Yeah.
My mom raised me on her.
- I love Barbara Streisand.
I would have met Barbara Streisand.
We have the same birthday, it's not fair.
- She's amazing.
We were at the Oscars and I turned around,
and she's like, "Hello Jason",
and I'm like,
- Oh my God she said your name.
- [Jason] Freaking out.
- Yes!
- She knew my name.
- [Kelly] Yes.
Everyone does.
- Babs knows my name.
- [Kelly] Babs.
- Couldn't believe it.
I just kept thinking,
my mom's gonna, oh my
god if my mom was here,
my mom would freak out.
- You grew up listening to her?
- Christmas doesn't start
until that album comes out.
- Oh my gosh, I love it.
- It's an amazing album. If
you'd have never heard it,
it's the best Christmas album.
- I love her.
Yeah, one of the greatest
singers, actors, of all time.
Yeah, she's so great.
You just met Clint Eastwood
too, right, recently?
- Just left, yeah, yesterday.
- [Kelly] Wow, what was that like?
Was he real quiet and intimidating?
- [Jason] No, he smiled too,
cause I was like "Oh, man".
- [Kelly] Look at the difference.
- [Jason] I'm like, "These are my kids!
Get over here now, it's Clint".
Get over here!
- [Kelly] Now!
- Smile!
Smile!
[Audience] (clapping).